when you have a chance to sit back and
reflect on all the tremendous
experiences you've had where you've gone
what you've accomplished performing in
front of 7.5 million people
live
what do you think you're going to think
about that experience seems much bigger
when you say they're live on the end
yeah it does yeah
we've done five albums five tours in
five years harry sat down with e.t in
2015 when one direction was at its peak
[Music]
they were just about to release made in
the am with anthems like history
[Music]
[Applause]
and drag me
down can drag me
down you can't win at music you you
can't there's obviously a pressure but i
think when you when you write
the record you don't make it and go out
with this we're trying to make a number
one record ultimately what's most
important is
making a group of songs that you think
the fans are gonna like and they did the
album was certified platinum in a matter
of months we're very lucky to have those
kind of markers as achievements but the
success together had a shelf life by the
time this album dropped zayn malik had
already split and the rest of the band
went on an indefinite hiatus just a few
months later all of the members choosing
to do their own thing including harry
it's not fair
survival's not fair in 2017 he made his
feature film debut in dunkirk i mean i
was so excited i think it's a movie that
i would be very excited to watch as a
fan had i not been involved in it the
spirit that you get from from soldiers
is there's no there's no hierarchy
there's nothing about what people's jobs
were before they got to war everyone's
in a uniform and everyone's the same and
you're just looking at the person next
to you and released his first solo album
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it came with a signature style one
that's turned him into a modern fashion
icon
[Applause]
another album and a grammy award later
harry is now part of the mcu with this
cameo as eros and the eternals last year
the end credits scene even surprised
doctor strange are you excited about
harry styles joining the marvel universe
i didn't even know he was i'm sorry
where do we see harry you know coming
into the the play i mean i've seen it so
we know we have a lot of fans
outside the studio of course but within
the studio of star fox of that character
eros so as the as the mcu has continued
into the cosmic arena
there are ideas and soon we'll get a
peek at the project that led him to his
real-life love olivia wilde she directed
him in the psychological thriller don't
worry darling with florence pugh due out
in september
[Music]
you